Você sabia que tem gente tomando o
Rakutã três vezes sem resolver a acne
porque o problema real está no
intestino? Veja bem, saiu essa história
de uma mulher que estava prestes a
começar o terceiro ciclo de Rocutã.
Terceiro. Mas sabe o que descobriram? A
acne severa dela era causada por doença
celíaca. O glúten estava inflamando o
intestino dela e a pele estava só
refletindo esse caos interno. E não é só
a doença celíaca, não. Sensibilidade ao
glúten, outras intolerâncias
alimentares, intestino inflamado, tudo
isso pode aparecer na sua pele como
acne. É que a gente tem mania de olhar
só o sintoma, né? Vê espinha, passa o
remédio pra espinha, mas o corpo não
funciona em compartimentos separados. O
intestino e a pele conversam o tempo
todo. Então, antes de partir pro
Rocutan, que tal investigar se o
problema não está no que você come? Às
vezes a solução está no prato e não na
farmácia. Pense nisso.